OK, I want to pick up on this idea of the
U.S. having the lowest fatality rate when
it comes to Corona virus.
Donald Trump has been saying this a lot and
said it to Chris Wallace during that completely
Gong Show Fox News interview that we looked
at earlier.
And there are different metrics for different
questions.
And you are.
I'm not saying you're being tricked, but there
are attempts being made to trick you, which
hopefully you aren't falling for.
So let's start at the beginning.
If we want to know where more people are dying,
you look at the number of deaths, right.
The problem is that number would not be adjusted
for the population because different countries
have different populations.
So we want to look at per capita.
If I say to you, a thousand people died of
the virus in the U.S. and a thousand people
died in Norway.
It's a thousand people in both cases.
But Norway has a smaller population.
So a thousand people dying.
There is more per capita than in the United
States.
That's very simple.
But I want to go in much more detail and look
at three different metrics and tell you where
they work and where they don't work.
We have deaths per capita.
We have the case fatality rate and we have
the infection fatality rate.
Yesterday, Donald Trump, in his interview
with Chris Wallace, said we have one of the
lowest fatality rates in the world.
And they put up a graph that the White House
gave Fox News.
And in this one, you have the U.K. at the
top.
You have the U.S. in the middle.
And you have Russia sort of closer to the
bottom.
But if you look at the top of this page, this
is the case fatality rate.
So the case fatality rate is simply deaths
divided by confirmed cases.
So as you can immediately notice, the case
fatality rate depends on the number of tests
that you do if one person dies and one hundred
people tested positive.
That is a case fatality rate of one percent.
One out of 100.
Notice that you can lower your case fatality
rate by doing more tests if one person dies.
But a test, a hundred more people meaning?
Now, I've done 200 positive tests.
Now your case fatality rate is only zero point
five percent.
Nothing has changed about the portion of the
population that has died.
You've just tested more people and lowered
your case fatality rate.
So as you can see, you can lower CFR by testing
more people.
Interestingly, Trump's strategy has been to
test fewer people, which hurts his own strategy
of focusing on case fatality rate.
So that gets us to infection fatality rate.
So when you look at infection, fatality, that's
deaths divided by the total believe the number
of infections.
So remember, we're not testing everybody.
There are people who have had coronavirus
who never got a.
So when we have 100 positive tests, we have
to estimate, well, how many people were really
infected?
We might determine that there's a 2.5 times
infection rate.
So for every hundred tests that go positive,
you estimate you really have 250 believed
cases.
So the infection, fatality rate with one death,
over 250 believed cases is only zero point
four percent.
Now, what's important is you can lower your
infection fatality rate by arguing that there
were way more asymptomatic people that had
the virus and recovered and are fine.
So if I argue, you know, for every positive
test, there's probably 10 people who had it,
I lower my infection fatality rate dramatically.
That now gets us two deaths.
Per capita deaths per capita are not tied
to testing or any speculation about asymptomatic
spread.
You're simply dividing deaths by population
one death in a country of 100 people.
That's one percent deaths per capita.
Notice that deaths per capita only goes up
over time, assuming that the population isn't
growing explosively during a pandemic.
So when a second person dies in a country
of 100, your deaths per capita are now up
to two percent.
This is important because deaths per capita
won't be impacted by the testing level.
Deaths per capita won't be impacted by your
estimate of how many asymptomatic cases they
are.
And when you look at that, the U.S. is currently
10th highest in the world.
Are deaths per million are 432.
We're right behind Chile, which is at 442.
So out of 200 plus countries and territories,
we are tenth in the world.
If you get rid of San Marino and Andorra,
which are tiny, and when you include countries
so small, it can sometimes be deceptive.
We're really eighth in the world among reasonably
sized countries.
So the way that deaths per capita can be affected
is that there could be corona virus deaths
that aren't being counted as corona virus
deaths.
So you have to look at excess deaths compared
to last year.
If you do that, it seems as though we are
probably undercounting the number of corona
virus deaths.
So now, you know, when Trump says we have
the lowest death rate, he's probably referring
to the case fatality rate, even though he's
also wrong that ours is low.
But really, we should focus on deaths per
capita over time.
If you want to compare how countries are doing,
you want to look at deaths per capita.
If you want to look at how deadly the disease
is among people who get it, you would look
at CFR and IFR.
But for for Trump's purpose, which is compare
how we're doing to other countries deaths
per capita is the metric that we should be
looking at.
And of course, it's never the metric that
Trump or Calima Kennedy or any of them are
actually talking about.
Hopefully this is useful.
And we'll have some of the example data on
the show's Instagram page.
Follow us on Instagram.
David, tachy text, The David Pakman Show David
Pakman dot com.